مدير مكتب الجزيره في رمضان وليد مع
الاعلان الجديد اليوم الذي بات شبه روتيني
للمؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه بمقتل مزيد
من الجنود والضباط الملاحظ هنا وليد
ارتفاع اعداد قتلى الضباط كما هو الحال
بالنسبه لارتفاع اعداد قتلى قوات النخبه
هل هل يبدو هذا الامر طبيعيا بالنسبه
للداخل
الاسرائيلي ليس طبيعيا لانه ومنذ فجر
السبت الماضي لغايه فجر هذا اليوم
الاربعاء نتحدث عن اربعه ايام قتل فيها 26
جنديا وضابطا اعلن الجيش عن اسمائهم
بالاضافه لعشرات من الجنود الذين ينقلون
الى المشافي من خلال الوحده وحده الانقاذ
والاسعاف العسكريه
669 المروحيات الاسعاف تقوم يوميا بالهبوط
في مستشفيات تل ابيب والقدس بالاضافه الى
سروق في بئر السبع وبرز لاي في عسقلان وهي
تنقل المصابين والجرحى والقتلى وهم بالفعل
هناك عدد كبير من الضباط هناك عدد كبير من
قوات النخبه ومعركه الشجاعيه على وجه
الخصوص التي يقول الجيش انه اجهز على
كتيبه القسام النخبوي فيها وانه قتل نحو
1000 من كوادرها هذه المعركه التي كانت
هناك قد اوقعت خسائر فادحه في راس الحربه
للواء جولاني وهو الوحده او الكتيبه 133
التي قتل قائدها وقتل منها عشرات من
جنودها وضباطها هذا مؤشر في نظر الشارع
الاسرائيلي والجيش الاسرائيلي والمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين على
قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا كتائب
القسام التي تقود هذه المقاومه وبانها
تعمل وفق خطط وان لديها كوادر من النخبه
قادره على الانقضاض وايضا
اسقاط قتلى وجرح في صفوف القوات
الاسرائيليه ثانيا منذ اكثر من شهر
والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين ومصادرهم الامنيه
والعسكريه تتحدث ب كانت تتحدث في حينه عن
ان هناك بدايات انكسار في قوات القسام
والمقاومه في قطاع غزه ونحن الان كما قلت
على مسافه شهرين من بدايه العمليه البريه
الاسرائيليه التي بدات في الثاني في ال 26
من اكتوبر الماضي تخل لها فقط اسبوع من
الهدنه وعمليات صف صفقات تبادل الاسرى
والتي بدات من بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه في
اقصى شمال قطاع غزه وما زالت وزال القتال
متواصل في هذه المناطق ايضا والثلاثه
الذين اعلن عن مقتلهم صباح اليوم وهم ضابط
وجنديين من لواء جفعاتي وهو ايضا مماثل
لجولي قتلوا في شمالي قطاع غزه اي في
معاركه في شمالي قطاع غزه ال المعارك
ومثلما افاد الزميل هشام هي تتركز بالفعل
في منطقه جباليا لكن هناك غارات وعمليات
ما يصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي بحرب عصابات
تشنها عناصر المقاومه التي تتحرك وتنقض
بخلايا من عنصرين الى ثلاثه او في بعض
الاحيان عنصر واحد فقط يقوم بشن غاره
والعوده او الانسحاب من الموقع لذلك الجيش
الاسرائ يقول انه اوشك على ان يحكم
احتلاله لمناطق شمال قطاع غزه لكن ما زالت
المعارك في هذه المنطقه متواصله وطائراته
قصفت مواقع حتى في حي الشيخ رضوان الشمالي
لمدينه غزه وايضا في مناطق بيت لاهيه وبيت
حانون وفي مقابل ذلك يتواصل القتال الضاري
على نحو غير مسبوق في منطقه خانيونس هذه
المدينه التي يعتبرها الجيش الاسرائيل
المعقل الاساسي لكتائب القسام لقادتها
وكوادرها ويقول بانه يخوض قتالا فوق الارض
وتحت الارض في هذه المدينه يقول انه يحقق
تقدما بطيئا لكن القتال ضار والاثمان
باهظه جدا والقوات التي تقوم بهذه
ال المعارك وهذا التحرك العسكري هي من
وحدات النخبه سواء في قوات الهندسه او
البر واليابسه مثل جولاني وكتائبه وايضا
في ايضا دوريات خاصه من دوريات رئاسه
الاركان الى
دوريات دوريات اخرى نخبويا حتى من سلاح
الجو ومن الكتائب الاخرى لذلك نسمع هذا
القتل في صفوف الضباط والجنود المتواصل
والمعارك ضاريه للغايه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بدا يتحدث ومن خلال متحدث والمحررين
العسكريين الذين يسرب لهم المعلومات وايضا
تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين انه على
وشك الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه من هذه
الحرب وهو ما كان الامريكيون قد اقنعوا
الاسرائيليين به من خلال زياراتهم وايضا
مستشاريهم والمرحله الثالثه التي يتوقع ان
تبدا مع نهايه الاسبوع الاول من الشهر
المقبل هي تقول بانه ستتحول الحرب الى حرب
استنزاف اي الخروج خروج القوات
الاسرائيليه المؤله والمدرعه الكبيره
والهائل التي اقتحم بها قطاع غزه خروجها
من المناطق الماهوله والبقاء على اطرافها
وفي مقابل ذلك يقوم بعمليات اغاره
واستباحه لباقي المناطق في قطاع غزه
تحديدا في مناطقها الجنوبيه ولديه خطه
تسربت المعلومات عنها منذ بدايه الحرب
لكنها عادت وتعززت هذه المعلومات في
الساعات ال 2ب الاخيره وهي اقامه شريط
امني على طول الحدود بعمق الاراضي
الفلسطينيه على طول الحدود في قطاع غزه
بعمق قد يترا يصل الى 1 كم وايضا تقسيم
قطاع غزه الى منطقتين شماليه وجنوبيه من
منطقه وادي غزه اي من منطقه جحر الديك في
الشرق حتى منطقه الساحل البحر ويكون هناك
شريط بعرض نحو كيلو بعرض نحو كيلو متر
يحكم عليه الجيش الاسرائيلي لتقسيم القطاع
بين شمالي وجنوب ولكن شمال قطاع غزه كانت
تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيلي منذ البدايه
وعادت من جديد لتتحدث عن تحويله الى منطقه
غير صالحه للحياه وما ينقله الزملاء
والدفاع المدني عن الوضع في شمالي قطاع
غزه فقد تحول الى مقابر جماعيه بفعل القصف
والقتل الاسرائيلي المتواصل والذي لا يرحم
احدا وكما تفيد وزاره الصحه هناك فان
الشهداء بالمئات بمعنى ان اسرائيل تتحدث
وهذه التصريحات رسميه اصبحت عن ان الحرب
امامها نحو عام على الاقل حتى تتمكن من
الاجهاز على حركه حماس بقدراتها العسكريه
والسلطوية
هي الان لدى القيادتين السياسيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه هي ل مساله الاستمرار في هذه
الحرب حتى نهايتها من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري شكرا جزيلا لك